6 26 on your monday morning got a viewer  question about the future path of i-11  in the las vegas syria gentleman by the  name of kirk writes in hey wasn't may  when the i-11 route was supposed to be  decided when are we going to know if  it's going to follow the beltway or  along us-95 pretty good timing kirk  while there's still not a final answer  there has been a preliminary  recommendation that the 95 515 through  las vegas becomes i-11 leaving the 215  as it is a planning and environmental  study that started three years ago is  over but you can still weigh in during  the 30-day comment period that started  last week we've got that link in the  online version of this story on our  website when you click traffic then  driving you crazy thanks again for  writing in kirk buckle up drive  carefully please put down that phone  something driving me crazy email me  traffic 8 8newsnow.com